[MUSIC]
Where are you from?
Chicago.
No, where are you really from?
The South side side of Chicago?
No, what are you?
For years, I couldn't explain why
incidents like this made me feel so
uncomfortable.
You speak such good English,
you must be good at math.
Your people's food is so spicy.
Innocuous on the surface,
but when repeated 10,
20, 50 times,
I would start to get annoyed.
But these were just curious people
with good intentions, right?
What right did I have to be annoyed?
It wasn't until I was in
college that I realized what
I was experiencing were
racial microaggressions.
Psychologist Derald Wing Sue
defines microaggressions as brief,
everyday exchanges that send
denigrating messages to
certain individuals based
on their group membership.
While they can be the product
of environmental or
behavioral slights,
most of the time they are unintentional.
And they happen all the time.
In fact, in a recent survey that
I sent out to my GSB classmates,
77% of respondents identified as having
been the victim of a microaggression.
So why do we care?
Well, take this example.
When a young woman repeatedly hears,
you have a great shot at that
promotion because they need
a female on their leadership team.
She starts to feel like she doesn't
deserve to be there based on
her own merits alone.
She starts to feel like
she doesn't belong.
Think that was too extreme of an example?
Take my opening question.
No, where are you really from,
implies that Chicago
cannot be a valid answer.
I cannot be American.
I must be a foreigner.
I cannot claim to be from the place
that I'm from because of how I look.
And I perpetually don't belong.
Now, the purpose of my talk today
is not to play the victim or
to even fantasize about a perfect world
where there are no microaggressions.
That would be unrealistic, because of all
of the unique backgrounds, experiences,
and implicit biases that everybody on
this Earth carries with us, me included.
Instead, I want to recognize
that these tiny snubs exist.
All of us commit them, and
that's going to happen.
While our intent is not
necessarily malicious,
different comments land with
different people in different ways.
And I'm here, firstly,
to bring awareness to that fact of life.
And more importantly, to tell you
what I've learned we can do if and
when we find ourselves on either
end of a microaggression.
A couple of years ago,
I had a boss casually throw me the advice
to act more like the men in the room.
I was stunned, I had no words
to express how I was feeling.
So I just said okay, and
walked back to my desk.
Six months passed, and I heard those
words haunting me every single day.
You should act more like a man.
Being a woman is not good enough.
My sense of self worth, my confidence,
and my productivity took a hit,
as I desperately tried to figure out
how to make sense of that comment.
How could we have avoided this situation?
Let's turn to the receiving end.
There are three things that you can do
when you find yourself the recipient of
a microaggression.
First and most importantly,
prioritize yourself.
There are situations where it
doesn't make sense to respond.
If I had gotten this comment from
a stranger I'd never see again, or
perhaps if my safety could have
been compromised if I did respond,
I would give myself the permission
to not say anything.
And I know that it's unfair that
the emotional burden of whether or
not to respond falls on the recipient.
But the more comfortable we get
with drawing boundaries and
predicting the implications to our lives
if we do not respond, the easier it gets.
Second, if you're in a place to,
ask clarifying questions.
I could have simply asked my boss,
what exactly do you mean by that?
He likely would have said something
about how I should be more confident, or
how I should be more aggressive
with my good opinions.
No malintent, great.
And third,
if you have the emotional bandwidth to,
state how the comment impacted you.
In one of the GSB's flagship classes on
interpersonal dynamics, we always talk
about how I cannot assume your intent,
since that's something only you know.
And that you cannot assume the impact
that your words have on me,
since that's something only I know.
In the class, we call these
assumptions crossing the net.
In the case of a microaggression,
if it is productive to state how
the comment made you feel,
it can help the perpetrator learn and
perhaps change their behavior for
next time.
In my example,
I could have simply told my boss,
when you tell me to act like a man,
I feel frustrated and dejected.
Because I can never be
enough due to who I am.
I did eventually confront my boss and
tell him this, and
I remember he looked shocked.
He fumbled and admitted that he hadn't
realized that's how I had taken it,
and that his intent was
just to be helpful.
He did apologize for
the effect that his advice had on me, and
I immediately felt like
a part of the team again.
Let's quickly turn to the giving end.
A couple years ago I was joking with my
friends in Seattle about our experiences
living there, when my friend made a
comment about the lack of diversity there.
To which I said, [LAUGH] what do you care?
You're just a straight, white man.
I watched his face fall, and
immediately knew that I had crossed
a line that I hadn't meant to.
Being the perpetrator of more than a few
of these kinds of careless comments
has taught me three things that you
can do when you find that you've just
committed a microaggression.
First, accept the other person's truth.
If they tell you how you made them feel,
don't cross the net.
Trust their reality and use it to
inform how you show up next time.
Which leads me to number two,
be open to change and
learn from the experience.
Not only can that help you
do better next time, but
that can help you become
a better ally if you see similar
microaggressions being
committed by others.
And third,
if you find yourself feeling guilty,
remember we are only human.
Everybody makes mistakes.
Microaggressions are largely
unintentional.
And their impact is not even uniform
across members of the same group.
Different comments land with
different people in different ways.
And while it's more than okay to be
curious about where I'm from, the decision
to reject my truth turns ignorance into
malice, and small pinches into a bruise.
It would be naive to think that we
can completely rid the world of
microaggressions.
But we can react to them
in a more productive way,
by strengthening our muscles of asking
the questions and trusting the responses.
It is my hope that we are all
better equipped to handle this
world's inevitable imperfect situations
with greater empathy and trust.
So that nobody feels like they
don't belong, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]